I Have No Clue!
Why are people unaware that they use products from companies they hate all the time?
For example, people who do not support tobacco companies use products from Philip Morris,...
...including Oreos, Kraft cheese, Kool-aid, etc.
The list goes on forever.
Well, the only way to avoid those products would be to do some research.
Don't take this the wrong way.
There are people who do the necessary research.
But most people don't bother doing it.
They don't know that the products they use every day are owned by the same companies that they hate supporting.
Think about it.
It's hard to keep track of all the products on the market!
Not everyone has the time to research and memorize exactly which company owns which brand,...
...on top of trying to research and memorize which companies should be boycotted in the first place.
Don't get me wrong, I'm not criticizing people who do that, like you, maybe.
Anyway, it's sad but true that we end up using products from the very companies that we don't support.